Munich's lane the house underwent four
years of construction and renovations
now its reopening with a polished new
look was it worth the wait if you think
this is just another piece of flashy all
style no substance modern architecture
think again the lane Bock house is in
Munich but its overhaul was conceived in
London Lord Norman Foster and his team
of Architects have been acclaimed for
their sensitive restorations of famous
old buildings such as the glass
Reichstag dome in Berlin and London's
British Museum the lembeh house was
conceived as a studio and villa at the
end of the 19th century it was never
meant to accommodate a flow of 280,000
people a year because it was the
residence the villa was originally built
for the wealthy painter Franz von Lane
back in 1929 the building was turned
into a museum its international
reputation grew with the decades and
with a series of architectural
modifications an extension built in the
early 1970s however was deemed surplus
to requirements for the current foster
redevelopment over time the original
building had been changed and in some
ways lost its roots trying to adapt to a
huge volume of visitors so this was an
opportunity to rediscover its roots to
extend it and bring back those original
qualities the 56 million euro remodeling
project was the idea of this man Helmut
Friedel director of the lane Bach house
he had no qualms about the modernization
process taking four years visa one thing
was always paramount for me and the
architect thank God we wanted the old
three wing structure incorporating the
historical garden in the Leanback house
to be retained more or less untouched
the former main entrance
now the Gateway to the garden is a
listed structure as are all the
buildings the complex was designed in
Italian Renaissance style
what used to be the FOIA now houses a
collection of Contemporary Art forming
the new entrance is a glass structure
that connects the original building with
the new two-story wing at the very spot
where the 1970s extension once stood
inside the architects decided to make
the old villa the centerpiece of the new
atrium visitors can look forward to
stunning views into and out of the
private chambers of the original owner
and resident franz von lima
reaching down from the ceiling of the
atrium is a spectacular vortex shaped
installation by Olafur Eliasson
that reflects light and color like a
kaleidoscope it's a sculpture that
spirals up and down creating dynamic
with two functions on the one hand
visitors just arriving are drawn up
towards the galleries at the same time
the range and vibrancy of colors in the
panes of glass is a reference to the
world of painting especially the blue
rider group the Malibu in space on the
display light that's of horizon as well
as its established collection of early
modern painting the Newland Bock house
has also expanded its range of
Contemporary Art
this was the main reason for the 20%
increase in exhibition space the
building's dimensions are far from
overwhelming however and very much in
keeping with Foster's model of make it
more domestic he's in has certainly each
room has its own personal character it's
as if you're visiting an art lover
friend at home instead of having works
of art in a cold formal setting they're
presented to viewers in an intimate way
from the inside you can see not only the
art but also the facade of the new
extension the golden metal rods were a
conscious choice imagine different
colors black white whatever they would
see more out of place than this metal a
golden facade as the artworks and
installations inside likewise shot
while modern urban architecture is
smoothly incorporated into the
neoclassical buildings comprising
Munich's Art District this is the
exciting new thing is that the building
links the old and new in a dynamic yet
elegant way the lane pas house Villa is
reborn as the famous gallery and museum
are transplanted into the 21st century